bonsoir mesdames messieurs il évite à
ottawa capitale fédérale
c'est avec cette introduction un peu
austère que débuter la soirée électorale
de 1962 mesdames messieurs bonsoir ici
lucien côté du service des nouvelles de
radio-canada 60 vite caméras de
télévision sont prêtes à transmettre les
images pour l'époque c'était le sommet
avec ceux qui comptabilisait les votes
et avec une certaine désinvolture pour
le québec on n'hésitez pas à en griller
une sur le plateau la soirée était très
très longue
heureusement il y avait les publicités
de café pour tenir le coup et puis les
premiers résultats avec la technologie
de l'époque la projection à ibm est la
suivante 1 oui cette curieuse machine
est bel et bien l'ordinateur à
prédictions avec les moyens
technologiques qui s'améliore les
soirées électorales fonctionne grâce à
des équipements que ne renierait pas la
nasa enfin presque
1974 on montre même les coulisses de
soirée électorale avec la musique des
pas
camatte à 282 avec raymond saint-pierre
gérard de sel jean yves michaud dans
chaque soir et c'est toujours l'occasion
de présenter toute une brochette de
journalistes
et puis le maître de cérémonie bernard
de rome qui sera là pour plusieurs
décennies déjà depuis une heure
une soirée électorale c'est aussi le
suspense qu'il faut dix tiller toute la
soirée
sans trop en dévoiler à 20 heures
précises nous aurons des résultats des
choses extrêmement précises ce que j'ai
besoin de faire un dessin
on se pensait dépenser bernard voie de
donner des résultats mais
malheureusement le format de l'annnonce
de la fameuse tendance qui se maintient
lui n'a pas vraiment changé à bas que si
la tendance se maintient depuis 1962
donc il n'y a pas que les modes qui ont
évolué et le développement technologique
internet ou encore les réseaux sociaux
ont changé la donne avec la publication
des résultats avant même que tout le
monde ait voté à l'autre bout du pays
voilà mais la seule chose immuable c'est
le pouvoir que vous avez toujours celui
de voter radio canada nous vous
souhaitons une très bonne pas nui
conjoint
[Musique]